depuis le début de cette guerre on l'a
dit le nombre de réfugiés et de déplacés
ukrainien n'a pas cessé d'augmenter près
de cent cinq mille personnes ont trouvé
refuge en moldavie nos envoyées
spéciales km h à bord et nadia massy se
sont rendus dans un centre d'accueil le
principal point d'entrée en moldavie de
ces réfugiés au portage
ici au centre de tri de palanca des
navettes comme celle ci il y en a des
dizaines chaque heure venant directement
de la frontière ukrainienne à trois
kilomètres d'ici à leur bord des
réfugiés venant directement de me coller
fuyant les bombes ou encore d'odessa par
l'anticipation de crainte d'une attaque
russe des familles essentiellement des
femmes des personnes âgées ou encore des
enfants qui ont laissé leur mari leur
fils en ukraine et ont dû abandonner
leur foyer ils sont souvent fatigués et
parfois traumatise écoutez
madame en jetant à chevaux mais
ce n'est pas parce que tu as a new day
pour les accueillir de multiples
organisations humanitaires qui leur
apporte un plat chant mais aussi des
fruits ou encore du lait et qui ont
affronté ses membres bus à destination
de différentes capitales européennes que
ce soit en bulgarie en pologne ou en
slovaquie une manière de désengorger
chisinau qui fut face à cet afflux de
réfugiés un craignant depuis le début de
la crise
[Musique]